[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing horcruxes
as well as a figure in harry potter
folklore that you may not know
it very well herpo the foul herpa the
fowl was an ancient
dark wizard that hailed from greece we
don't have an exact date
as to when herpa walked the earth but we
do know that it was a long
long time ago as he is commonly referred
to as one of the earliest
known dark wizards it was a time when
magic was
not new but being pushed more than ever
in terms of its limits
particularly on the darker side of the
spectrum
this is largely in part due to the
ongoing wizarding muggle conflict
where witches wizards were being
demonized and hunted
by the muggle population the wizard and
the hopping pot
a short story from beedlen and nabard
explains the state of wizard muggle
affairs
accurately as the witch hunts grew ever
fiercer wizarding families began to live
double lives using charms of concealment
to protect themselves and their families
by the 17th century any witch or wizard
who chose to frastronize with muggles
became suspect even an outcast in his or
her own community
many witches and wizards were forced to
hide to retreat
taking the moral high ground by not
retaliating and potentially making the
situation
more dire however some witches and
wizards
wizards like herpo the fowl used this
era to practice
the worst kinds of dark arts imaginable
all in the name of retribution where a
morally good magical practitioner in
this time
may have practiced something like a
concealment charm in hopes of better
hiding the wizarding population
his evil counterpart would likely spend
his efforts trying to produce a spell
that could eradicate muggles herpo
devoted his life to producing and
creating
some of the worst kinds of magic
imaginable similar to the story of a
christus
the possible father of dementors who
solitarily dabbled in black magic
on the remote island vazkaban in the
16th century
herpa was possibly the original parcel
mouth meaning he can speak to snakes
and for this reason i believe that he
was possibly the distant ancestor
of both voldemort and salazar slytherin
herpo's affinity for snakes
also led to his creation of the very
first basilisk
remember them but basilisk creation is
not where herpo
stopped for years he continually pushed
the boundaries of magic
and ultimately became the first wizard
ever to produce
one of the darkest forms of magic
achievable the subject of this video
a horcrux a horcrux is an object in
which a dark witch or wizard
has imbued part of their soul the
ultimate purpose of creating a hawk rugs
is to achieve immortality however the
truly sinister component of creating a
horcrux
is that in order to produce one you must
murder someone
when one thinks of horcruxes we most
commonly jump to voldemort
since he was able to produce seven
marvolo gaunt's ring the diary of tom
riddle
helga hufflepuff's cup salazar the rin's
locket
rowena ravenclaw's diadem nagini and
even
harry potter sort of however what people
often overlook
is that herpo is the original horcrux
creator
and this arguably makes him even more
sinister because
as the first practitioner of this type
of magic i can't even begin to imagine
what sorts of dark arts experiments he
overlooked in order to achieve his
goal what is also worth mentioning
however is that herpo and voldemort are
the only witches and wizards
to have ever produced a horcrux at all
this either tells me that they are
particularly talented
particularly demented or a combination
of both jk rowling has openly stated
herself
that many witches and wizards had tried
to create one but
none succeeded wizards would have been
looking for ways to do exactly what
voldemort did for years
and some of the ways they would have
tried would have killed them so i
imagine it well they're huge parallels
splitting the atom would be a very good
parallel in our world
i do imagine that other people are going
to have tried i think it would be naive
not to think
that people have been trying for a long
time and thought they succeeded and
hadn't
or else maimed themselves or killed
themselves in the attempt
it's such a dangerous thing to do so why
did voldemort create horcruxes in the
first place
well to achieve immortality of course
the sole function of a horcrux is to
preserve and extend your life force
and one thing that i find particularly
interesting is that it is unknown
whether herpo is actually alive or not
in present day if herpa made a horcrux
then there's still a very good chance
that he's alive
right by the time voldemort came around
the horcrux creation process was
outlined in a book
called secrets of the darkest art and
this is where i'm going to begin to
piece together my argument
for why herpo may still be alive
this is the one that gives explicit
instructions on how to make a horcrux
secrets of the darkest art it's a
horrible book
really awful full of evil magic here's
the thing
up until voldemort herpa was the only
wizard to have ever produced a horcrux
and it's likely that he was the only
wizard with any information on it
in order to properly understand magic
you need to practice it
as i don't believe that purely theory is
necessarily enough to warrant writing a
book
so if there's a book floating around
with information on the horcrux creation
process
it only makes sense that herpo himself
was in fact involved with said book
whether he simply contributed to the
contents of the book or if he wrote the
book under an alias
is unknown the current credited author
of secrets of the darkest art
is owl bullock a dark wizard that no one
really knows anything about
here's what i think herbert the fowl is
still alive
and he goes by the name old bullock
herpo hailed from ancient greek times
meaning that he has been around
for a very long time his horcrux secured
his immortality
and fearing that his horcrux could in
fact be destroyed
he decided to keep a relatively low
profile for the rest of his existence
knowing that he could better impart his
dark knowledge onto the world
if he remained alive perhaps though
immortal
herpo just wasn't that talented at
martial magic this would make his mind
far more of a threat than his
physicality i mean
look at the damage that his published
works caused presumably
that book as well as the information
provided from slughorn
is the very way that voldemort figured
out how to produce his own horcruxes
what better way to sustain your legacy
than passing on information pertaining
to the most twisted spell out there i'm
of the genuine impression that herpo is
still alive to this day
keeping a low profile i picture him as a
very unassuming man
in part thanks to transfiguration which
would have allowed him to alter his
appearance
perhaps herpos alias is even someone
that we know about or have seen
from the series so if he's still alive
that of course means that his horcrux is
still intact
this leads us to a new question
altogether what is herpa's horcrux
how has he been able to keep it a secret
for all of these years
i think the herpos horcrux is actually
an object that we're already familiar
with
the opal necklace the opal necklace is
first brought to our attention
quite early on in the books but the role
that it would play obviously doesn't
become clear
until much later on we first see the
necklace when harry mistakenly enters
borgen and berks in the year 1992
the sinister necklace was on display in
the unusual shop
complete with a warning label do not
touch cursed
has claimed the lives of 19 muggle
owners to date
after that the necklace isn't discussed
or seen again that is until the half
blood prince
when draco malfoy decides to use it for
dark deeds
katie bell is cursed by this very
necklace now
based on the fact that it's what appears
to be an inanimate object
and the fact that in order to be
subjected to its full evil nature you
need to touch it
i immediately began to form the
connection in my mind with voldemort's
horcruxes
the opal necklace is clearly an old
ancient
dark magical artifact and given its
questionable history
and the fact that you can't directly
handle it i'm sure someone has tried to
destroy it
at one point or another its existence in
the half-blood prince
however is certainly a testament to its
resilience and i think that its
durability
may be one of the reasons that points to
it being a horcrux
the opal necklace however certainly
doesn't keep much of a low profile
i think that the alternate approach that
herpo may have taken
would have been to turn an everyday
commonplace object into a horcrux
something unassuming that no one would
ever interact with or touch
what do you guys think does my theory
check out let me know in the comment
section
below until next time remember
fear of a name increases fear of the
thing itself
[Music]
you